We brought a trailer in for our micro entrepreneur offices
that is in front of our garden.
And so we have our garden and multiple garden beds
out on the patio.
We use the space where our apprentices eat their breakfast
and lunch for pop-up restaurants.
It's truly just, it's been a wonderful home for us,
but we are at the point that we have had to step back.
One of the reasons we no longer do hunger relief meals
on the regular is because our kitchen is only
so many square feet and we have to train our apprentices.
That's always the heart of our program.
And we are the meal contract
for the juvenile detention facilities.
And we're doing, you know, over three meals a day
for 300 kids, three snacks a day, 365 days a year.
And so some of that prep happens in our kitchen
and between the training and the micro entrepreneurs
and that meal contract, that kitchen is running
22 hours a day.